es una de las Estrellas ascendentes del
partido republicano y se subirá al ring
para disputar la nominación para la
presidencia en 2024
Ron de santis actual gobernador de
Florida continúa avanzando peldaños en
el bloque rojo de Estados Unidos y ya es
una amenaza para el expresidente Donald
Trump pero también una para el partido
demócrata sobre el que se impuso dos
veces en Florida un estado
históricamente en disputa
[Aplausos]
hemos logrado más de lo que nadie creía
posible Hace 4 años pero tenemos mucho
más por hacer y apenas he comenzado a
luchar Dios los bendiga a todos Muchas
gracias gracias por una histórica
victoria aplastante
de santis ha construido una figura de
conservador que no titubea en temas
controvertidos envió decenas de
inmigrantes a una pequeña Isla frente a
la costa de Massachusetts también
prohibió los abortos desde las seis
semanas de gestación emprendió una lucha
legal contra Disney tras quitarle su
estatus especial dentro del distrito
amplió la polémica ley no digas gay
según la denominaron los críticos que
prohíbe la instrucción en el aula sobre
asuntos lgbtq más y recientemente
promulgó una de las leyes anti
inmigración más restrictivas del país
para algunos analistas de santis cuenta
con favor dentro del partido Pero le
falta fortaleza a nivel nacional el
atractivo principal de ron de santis Es
que él no es Donald Trump Y eso atrae al
65% del partido republicano pero para
ganar las elecciones generales Este es
el gran signo de interrogación no solo
tiene que ganarse a los votantes
republicanos tiene que ganarse a las
personas que dirán que lo hará mejor que
Trump como antagonista republicano de
Trump de santis Buscar hacer el nuevo
hombre fuerte del partido